[موسيقى]
صوري اخوكم النوويه وقودها رقمي مشفر فخلف
هذه التجارب المكثفه تقف الاف القطع من
بيتكوين وشبيهتها بيونجا
بامتلاكها حوالي 1000 صاروخ بالستيه لم
يسبق لها ان اطلقت هذا الكلمه من الصواريخ
كما العام الحالي اكثر من 75 صاروخا 23
منها اطلقتها في الثاني من نوفمبر الجاري
وحده
ورغم ان تكلفه تصنيع هذه الصواريخ
وتجريبها قد تكون اقل تكلفه في كوريا
الشماليه مما هي عليه في بلدان اخرى الا
ان صحيفه لوفيجارو الفرنسيه قدر التكلفه
الصواريخ التي اطلقت هذا الشهر بين 50 و
75 مليون دولار وهو مبلغ ضخم بالنسبه لبلد
معزوله ومستهدف بالعقبات لكن للزعيم
الشمالي وقراصنه رايا اخر عام 2014 قام
قراصنه كوريون شماليون يعرفون باسم
لاسيروس باختراق بيانات شركه سوني بيكتشرز
اليابانيه ونفذ مئات اختراقات الفديه حول
العالم المجموعه نفسها كانت وراء سرقه
هائل للعملات المشفره بعد ان اخترقت شبكه
رونو للدفع الرقميه المستخدمه في لعبه اكس
انفينيتي وسرقه ما يعادل 615 مليون دولار
من العملات المشفره الامر تكرر عامي 2019
شروه 2020 فوفقا لخبراء الامم المتحده
استطاع قراصنه بيونغيانغ سرقه ما يفوق 315
مليون دولار من الاصول الافتراضيه اما هذا
العام فيقدر ما سرقه القراصنه الكوريون
الشماليون بملياردولار من العملات المشفره
هجمات الكترونيه تمنح كوريا الشماليه
طريقه رخيصه لكسب الكثير من المال